it's because of who we are right it's
cause like now we we have this little
show we do this little thing this little
show show you know and uh it's all it's
i think there's a lot more eyes on us
yeah so people
want to want to get angry uh
what we say you know because a lot of
the times people are getting annoyed at
this stuff aren't aren't the people who
like actually like watch trash taste
yeah like outside of trash taste maybe
have like some followers who've watched
trash taste maybe say some of the clips
or whatever and they're like you won't
believe what they these these guys who i
don't already watch or engage with said
like
they don't know how we we behave or how
we like go towards the topic or how we
tackle it it's just like he just said
this thing i disagree with it i'm gonna
get angry what's what's like really
weird especially about my jewish kya
kaisen hot take hot take is the fact
that i called juice like i said okay
months ago on my own channel yeah no one
[ __ ] batted a knife
right it's weird because like i feel
we've got to that point now where uh
like not super small twitter accounts
but some twitter accounts with some
decent followings will be like
this clown take on trash taste
yeah yeah yeah but i think that's also
kind of cool i'm like oh that's awesome
that people feel like i'm they're big
like we're big enough where they can
just openly like criticize us i mean
yeah like go ahead
it is it is humbling to think that my
offhand comment about an anime has like
stirred up this much controversy
it's kind of cool but at the same time
it's like can you not cancel me for
saying that a show is okay i could count
only sleepover if someone gets angry
over and i just think it's a little like
you know i'm glad i you know imagine uh
back four or five years ago if i'd said
the same [ __ ] no no one would give up no
okay i think i'm glad that people can't
sometimes it's annoying it's a little
too much i love it thank you for caring
about my dumb opinion about a show i
don't care about joe's opinion
i don't even care about my opinion i
just said it well i think the argument
is that you know we are you know
creators who have a platform and an
influence i mean that's why they call
people like us influencers right
even though we [ __ ] hate them i'm
allergic to that word i love it actually
you know i mean i'm i have the i got
like that evil voice going for me so i
feel like it works yeah someone calls me
an influencer yeah it's just like the
one thing i don't like about that word
is that it can apply to
so many things you know like a cult
leader is technically an influencer as
well those are the influences they're
the og influencers right like i don't
know if i want to be bunched up from
those guys i'm kidding by the way i i i
actually like the word i like to think
that i make something that's somewhat
entertaining and good yeah i'm just
gonna do it on the internet i don't know
yeah
yeah i'm with a bunch of hot days yeah i
mean i mean i i i feel like you know i i
get it to a certain extent where we do
have to you know be careful about some
of the stuff we say right because we you
know there are some topics that i feel
we do have to like navigate very you
know very carefully
because there are other creators out
there who do have a platform and uh
their word they say [ __ ] and uh their
words have a tangible effect on the real
world and the community they talk to
but at the same time
there there are some things that i just
like
it blows my mind that people care this
much about right right
and you know like one of one of the
biggest things that i don't understand
is you know people take this people will
people will take this you know one
minute two minute clip from trash taste
or from one of our streams because it's
happened to me a bunch of times right uh
where
where i will see this clip being
circulated where it's like a one or two
minute clip from the podcast or my
stream that's like not scripted it's
just in a conversation that's most of
the time doesn't even have anything to
do with the take that i'm saying in that
one clip because it's like one or two
minutes yeah yeah yeah and they will
take this clip and then spin it to like
a whole new level of i got it like
you've planned it all out yeah yeah yeah
yeah like it's a [ __ ] mastermind move
yeah yeah and like and like i think of
this in context right and i'm thinking i
don't think people who watch our show or
people who are super fans of the show is
going to be influenced by a one minute
clip of us talking about this one
subject that most of the time doesn't
even have to do with the overall
conversation it's just like it's just
most of the time just like an offhand
comment or something yeah i don't think
that's going to [ __ ] influence
anybody yeah like on that on that
segment where joe you spoke about
yourself and i was like no you're you're
a clown right it's good you know how if
you're a viewer it's like how can you
argue that then
you're being influenced to be like juju
kaisen is mit or okay because like
there's an active argument going on
where you're saying no it's it's not
you're wrong so like what do you think
well right you take away from that it's
not oh i'm going to think you're due to
carson's mid even if you're like a super
fan right it's so stupid but that's what
i think i like about you know those
kinds of discussions on the show
especially when like you know to to or
all of us uh like arguing against each
other right is that like it gives so
many different points of views where
like it's up to the viewers now who you
want to agree with right and it's like
it's not so much it's not so much me
saying hey because i think jesus christ
is okay you should also think that way i
mean if you want to think that way
that's on you right but it's not like
i'm coming out here you know [ __ ]
starting a demo of being like everybody
stand up and rise jesus christ is just
okay
okay and like start a [ __ ] coup
d'etat
right it's like
i'm just [ __ ] like
i just don't
yeah i just don't get it like you know
it's fine to be influenced by certain
things but at the same time
it's like
it's just a show
i think it's a good problem to have in
our job of course of course people would
uh
spend a lot lot many years trying to get
to the point where we're very fortunate
where you know people watch fashion
people care i feel very lucky that
people want to get angry about small
things like jokes yeah that's fine is it
is it you know is it a contention for
cancellation though i'm not sure about
that
i don't know it goes back to like online
hate day as well i mean i've gone to the
point now where it doesn't really bother
me that much at all really it's got it's
it's interesting i don't i think this is
just because i've been online for so
long now where now i'm just kind of like
at equilibrium with it i'm like i don't
know yeah it's it's i wouldn't even say
it's because like i'm okay with it now
or i'm like numb to it i guess it's like
i think i think jessica negri said it
best
uh she said when someone asked her about
like how do you deal with like internet
hate yeah like how do you get over it
yeah and she said like you never get
over it it still hurts but you just
learn to live with it like to to me to
me because we have talked about this a
few times but to me like you know
without getting to like the online hate
thing the thing that like the one thing
that annoys me then just people actually
actually just like hating on me and
hating on my content for example is just
when when people are like trying to put
words in my mouth yeah to be like to be
like gant said this or god said this and
that means x you know or that means x y
z and that that to me there's nothing
that wants to make me reply more than
people who are spreading this idea that
i s you know maybe others
it is right it is it is
because at that point like it's i've
seen some like instances where like you
know i say one thing right and then it
just like spirals out into this like
insane story about like how i [ __ ]
killed a child or something right like
it's like
like it's like that level of like how
did you take this one little piece of
information and spin it in a way that
it's just couldn't be further from the
tr like you're basically writing a fan
fiction at that point
and it's like it's like what and then
there are people who look at that and be
like oh yeah that's that sounds like
something he'd say i'm like what
i've been thinking about that
because i i swear to god i don't know if
they like i i don't know if the anime
community was always like this because
like to me there there are some there
are some topics that i always like used
to love arguing about you know because
i felt like to me you know there are
some things where you really have to be
careful about what you say in terms of
terms like religion politics and stuff
like that yeah that's the reason why we
never talk about well we've spoken about
a little bit yeah yeah we never actually
sometimes you just want to have like a
fun argument on someone where you can
you can just [ __ ] on your opinion and
you don't have to worry about about it
because you know that at the end of the
day the topic doesn't really matter that
much and to me like
as as an anime fan anime was always one
of those topics for me until like quite
recently and i don't know if that's just
my perception because like another topic
i would say is you can easily argue with
anyone about is food everyone loves
arguing about food we do it all the
[ __ ] time because it's fun and it's
fun because people understand that
people have different tastes and
opinions right and to me like anime was
always
at that same level as i can easily argue
about anyone with anime and not have to
worry about you know hurting their
feelings too much because i i just
assume we all everyone in our community
has like an understanding that yeah dude
you can have your own taste you can have
your own it's mutual agreement that at
the end of the day even if this one
random internet person doesn't think
that your favorite show is as good as it
is it's like well that's not going to
deter me from the fact that i still like
the show it's just changed just because
of the scale of trash taste right it's
like you know there's nothing like this
back in the day you know back in podtaku
what was the like average viewer count
like i think our most viewed podcast
ever was like 100k
which you know back then was crazy yeah
it's crazy that's amazing yeah you know
obviously the scale is completely
different now yeah anime has also been
somewhat more democratized in a way like
democratized
yeah definitely more it's more available
to more eyes it's a lot easier to get a
hold of
you know and discourse about it is way
more open and people are way more open
to talk about it so i think that's why
it's some of the reasons why so the
problem is it's getting popular well
essentially i mean
you could almost say it's becoming
mainstream
because i i was i i always had this like
image that
the anime community felt like it was
about like 10 5 10 years behind what we
saw with the gaming community right
because it felt like maybe gaming the
gaming industry also had this shift
where
games used to be just this fun things
you numb your numb your brain out to
didn't really matter that much you know
you could just have your fun with it and
then now games mean like games are a big
business
and it's the same yeah
i know that some people gave zelda
breath a while like a 7 out of 10 when
it came out and they got controversy for
that
because they didn't give it a 9 or 10 or
something so basically they got canceled
for saying breath of the wild was just
okay
they said it was just good
you know it's we've had the same thing
it's the same thing again isn't it
incredible how one word can completely
change everything like there's such a
huge difference in like insinuation
between calling something good and
calling something
just good it could be the attitude
towards it as well you know sometimes i
think uh
sometimes
i can understand sometimes the way you
talk about anime could definitely like
you're so like you're like yeah it's mid
and i can understand
why why you piss people off because you
sound like you won't even entertain the
conversation you're like i [ __ ] hate
the fact that you even brought this up
to me it was mid stop talking to me
about it so i can understand why
sometimes people can get annoyed by that
yeah like i wish joey just even listened
to me it's like me trying to get
approval from my parents it's like i
wish my parents just gave it a chance
like no no it's like you're like
you're like it's mid you know i think
maybe that's what annoys people i yeah
and and look i can completely get that
as well and that is my bad
but at the same time it's like you know
sometimes i don't even bother engaging
in these conversations because i already
know how it's going to end i i i get you
i get you joking because it's just it's
just happened so many times that i've
done this for almost nine years yeah i
know how a conversation like this is
going to end i i mean i've known you for
ages so yeah
i could give out all these like well
thought out constructed arguments about
why i think the show was okay and people
would be like but but but but but
i don't agree with that oh my god what
more can i say so what you're saying is
if trash day started six years ago you
might have got more enthusiastic debate
out there oh yeah dude
this would actually be an anime podcast
no no no no no i don't want an anime
podcast but no it's not it's not now
it's not now
it's great yeah
thank
you know going back to the hate thing
what's uh because you always get asked
right by new creators or something or
anyone uh how do you deal with online
hey what's what's the advice that you
give someone cause i've been i've been
mulling this over a lot recently because
i think my opinion on it has changed
quite a lot
since the last time we talked about this
i think so i think i had this like
perspective shift uh recently and i
don't know why um but i was like
the whole thing of uh living with it and
stuff is totally valid advice and i
think that's also good but i don't know
what happened but now i look at it and i
don't really care at all when i see it
because to me in my head
they're never angry at like me as a
individual person when i read that it's
like they're angry at like what they
think is me right right they're not
angry at if they sat with me and spoke
with me they probably wouldn't feel that
way right but yeah but they're angry at
the idea of me and and more often than
not it's like they
were never gonna give me a chance anyway
because i'm just i must be a personality
they don't like yeah see but like i feel
that way of thinking about things is
only
was has only been constructed because
you've been doing this for so long yeah
definitely and like i don't think there
are very very few people who can come
right into this industry from the jump
and have this like enough
self-confidence in themselves and their
content and their self-image on the
internet to be like well that's not
about me that's just about their image
of me right and i feel like you know
especially when i started off like i
didn't have that kind of [ __ ]
confidence right i'm sure a lot of
people didn't where you know so like
anything like the moment your name gets
mentioned in something and even if it's
not exactly the most like detrimental
thing you know jab at your personality
or whatever i think people just not used
to this and having this like random
amount of people coming up to you and
being like by the way your kind of [ __ ]
you know is a thing that we're not
really used to right because the human
wasn't involved how many people just
walk down the street and have a random
person be like excuse me you're [ __ ]
like no
it doesn't happen right but on the
internet that's normal and i think it's
like new york yeah exactly
who is it that said like people on the
internet have internet have gotten way
too used to saying things not getting
punched in the face for it yeah you're
like
absolutely there's no repercussion for
it right so it's like you know they they
just think oh it's just free range to
see the [ __ ] i want right oh sorry and i
was about to say like you know and yes
in a sense it is kind of free range to
say whatever you want but you know with
the repercussions you know like you can
say whatever you want as long as you're
willing to pay for the repercussions if
they come back to you right and they're
very well might you know yeah because
like i actually had to like train my mum
up for this like
recently because she she's not getting
hate but sometimes she goes through like
the trash taste videos and like you know
some of the streams and like the
comments and she like finds these
comments and like
god i want to reply right now i want to
tell them that they're wrong like mum do
not do that
do not do that that's even well
my mom does that because my mom my mom
reads like so many comments and like she
does she doesn't understand how to like
how to deal with online hate especially
to like her own son so she's just she's
just like well sometimes she'll just
like send me send me like a bunch of
[ __ ] comments being like look at all
these people saying wrong information
about you i want to reply is that one is
that like a southeast asian mom thing
because aki's mom does exactly the same
where she had to be like mom stop
sending me this [ __ ] stop replying to
this [ __ ] just leave it i'm fine i
literally have to explain to her it's
like it's like if a school bully said
something to me and you come up to the
school bully in front of everyone in the
school and be like don't talk don't talk
about my son like that
i'm like mom this looks even worse than
even if i reply to her personally
okay how did she take it how did she
take it i mean she i mean i told her not
to do it i'm just like don't you just
just don't read it mom just i i
understand what you're going through
everyone who's a content creator goes
through this at the beginning but you
just gotta understand that people are
gonna get just gonna stay stuffed and
actually couldn't be more the opposite
of that like my parents would be like oh
you know my dad would be like oh yeah
some people were saying [ __ ] about your
last video and i'm like really he's like
yeah but they're all dicks don't don't
worry about it
you're
i'm sweating for the day where i'm just
waiting for the day where i wake up on
twitter one day and then i wake up to
like a screenshot that's been spread
viral about my mum replying to like one
of my haters comments be like yo have
you seen what god's mom said to this
person i'm like for [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh my god i love that
i i think we should uh we need some
comments from your mom i think yeah
definitely i think that'd be good we
should have a segment we read out your
mum's reply
have your parents ever like look through
your comments or look through your
videos to see what people are saying
about you i think so i think my mum one
time was like really sad about it she
was like why are they saying mean things
there's on this one thing about you
right she's like don't worry about it
it's not a big deal she's like it's so
cute though right yeah she was way more
upset about it than i was yeah i don't
give a [ __ ] but you know
obviously because it's not normal to see
people bad mouth your
son yeah of course it's not a normal
thing you get to experience yeah it's
quite a visceral emotion i mean i i'd be
lying if i said if if my kid was in that
situation i wouldn't do the same thing
right oh yeah i'd probably want to punch
punch someone yeah i'd be like okay you
made my
yeah like honestly i kind of get it i'm
the same i guess because i i feel like
more anger when i see you know people's
[ __ ] talking sydney than i see when i
when i see people oh yeah it's the same
like
if i see one person [ __ ] talking when i
bros i'm just like [ __ ] that yeah yeah i
wanna i wanna [ __ ] call them out now
and and i guess like if in that vein
like the one i think the one thing i
hate more than people taking my [ __ ] out
of context right and trying to cancel me
for something completely related is when
they just like drag my friend into it
and especially people who like don't
matter at all i'm like okay you can say
[ __ ] about me right like i'll take care
of her that'll be my problem yeah but
don't drag people who have nothing to do
with this [ __ ] yeah don't drag in my
girlfriend or my friends or like my
[ __ ] mom or anything like this got
nothing to do with them if you hate my
opinion just [ __ ] talk me i'll i'll deal
with it i'll cry into my own pillow but
i won't i don't i don't want people [ __ ]
talking other people that's like the one
thing i hate don't do that you're a dick
if you do that you're a dick if you do
that